WAI CHEE DIMOCK: We're
moving on to
To Have and Have Not.
And this novel was written in
a fairly haphazard fashion.
It was written between
1935 and 1937.
Basically, it was written when
Hemingway was taking a break
from his coverage of the
Spanish Civil War.
So he would be in Spain for
the Spanish Civil War, and
then he would come back to the
United States, but actually
also to the Bahamas to write
To Have and Have Not.
So you guys know that
we'll be reading For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
For Whom the Bell Tolls and To
Have and Have Not are really
interlocking in multiple ways,
because one is about the
Spanish Civil War, and this
one's written when Hemingway
was covering the Spanish
Civil War.
So you can really think of those
as in dialogue in really
interesting ways.
A hotel that Hemingway stayed at
when he was writing To Have
and Have Not was
in the Bahamas.
It's in Bimini.
It's the Compleat
Angler Hotel.
Actually, the hotel burnt down,
so it's no longer there,
but this was a picture
taken before that.
That's really lucky that
there was this picture.
And inside there, there's a
plaque saying that this was
the home of Ernest Hemingway.
He was there for two years.
He probably wrote To Have and
Have Not in various different
places, but this was one of the
main places that he stayed
at when he wrote the novel.
As we also know, Cuba was very
important to Hemingway.
This is his house still
standing, the Finca Vigia,
which is now the Museo Ernest
Hemingway in Havana.
And this is a picture of
Hemingway writing.
He wrote The Old Man and the
Sea when he was in Cuba in
this very house, and all
his books were there.
But this picture was probably
taken a little
later, in the 1950s.
So I found some old pictures
of Havana in the 1930s.
This is the waterfront.
This is the El Malecon
with the seawall.
You can see there's some
really very magnificent
buildings on the waterfront.
And this is the main avenue,
the Avenida de los
Presidentes, a very, very
impressive-looking avenue.
Cuba was actually called the
Paris of the Western
Hemisphere in the first half
of the 20th century.
And we can see why.
It really was a very
magnificent place.
And this is downtown Havana,
still in the '30s.
And this is a bar that Hemingway
went to quite a lot.
It's the Sloppy Joe's Bar.
And here's a picture of him
and the British playwright
Noel Coward at the
Sloppy Joe's Bar.
So really interesting
historic pictures.
Other than drinking, Hemingway
also went fishing a lot.
As we can see, he has a very
intimate knowledge of fishing.
And the fish that especially
preoccupied him was the marlin.
So this is a description from To
Have and Have Not of what a
marlin looked like.
And I just happen to have
found this picture.
This doesn't correspond
exactly to that.
"The sword, the eye, and open
lower jaw, and huge
purple-black head of
a black marlin."
From this picture, we can't
really see how big it is.
This is a picture of Hemingway
on the boat Anita--
this was just before he wrote
To Have and Have Not--
with his friends.
And the next picture is taken
in Bimini with his second
wife, Pauline, and his three
sons, Gregory, John, and
Patrick, 1935.
And we can see just how
huge the marlin is.
It could weigh up
to 1,000 pounds.
So this picture I downloaded
online, thanks to the Ernest
Hemingway Collection at the
JFK Library in Boston.
So this is just to acknowledge
a very important collection.
If you guys want to do future
work on Hemingway, that's the
place to go.
It's helpful in thinking about
To Have and Have Not to think
a little bit about
the publication
history of this novel.
It was also published as
two short stories.
"One Trip Across" was
published in the
Cosmopolitan, 1934.
And then "The Trader's
Return" published in
Esquire magazine, 1936.
And then To Have and Have
Not was published by
Scribner's in 1937.
So because of the way it came
out initially as short
stories, I think once again
we have to think about the
narrative structure
of the novel.
And there's a lot to think
about, because it turns out
that this is an incredibly
complicated switching back and
forth between the first person
and the third person.
So part one is told in
the first person.
It seems very straightforward.
It's told from Harry Morgan's
point of view.
It's also the spring, the
section called "Spring." So it
is in many ways the spring
in Harry Morgan's life.
And then part two is told
in the third person.
And this is actually
quite jolting.
All of a sudden, we see Harry
Morgan from the outside as if
we knew nothing about him.
He's re-introduced to us as "he"
and even as "the man," a
very, very alienating
perspective in part two.
And that's the section
called the "Fall."
And then part three is called
the "Winter." And here, it's
even more complicated
than that.
It's mixed narration.
It begins with someone who's
not even a very important
character, someone called
Albert who tells the
story in Chapter 9.
And then it switches back to
Harry in Chapter 10, and then
we get third-person narration
for a good part of part three.
And then the very final chapter,
Chapter 26, it
switches back to the
first-person narration, but
it's told by Marie,
Harry's wife.
So at the very least, we can
say that Hemingway is
experimenting with all kinds of
narrative points of views.
And so the most fundamental
question
has to do with pronouns.
Who is attached to
which pronoun?
Why does Hemingway choose
to use certain pronouns?
Why does he choose to use
certain points of views for
that section?
And this is also a good moment
to start thinking about the
interconnections among
the novels.
I know that you guys just turned
in your first paper,
but it's not too early to start
thinking about the next
big project.
And the interconnections among
the novels would be a very
good approach.
Think about that
larger project.
So two things are very clear
in terms of the prior
publication as short stories.
To Have and Have Not obviously
looks back to In Our Time.
Hemingway's habit is to publish
parts as short stories--
actually, it's very common--
publish parts as short stories,
and then to have a
larger entity.
Whether or not the two are
related in terms of this prior
publication history is
a good question.
But To Have and Have Not is also
linked to The Sound and
the Fury because of the multiple
narrative voices.
In The Sound and the Fury, we
know that there are just four.
So the three brothers each gets
one section, and then the
omniscient narration
in section four.
In To Have and Have Not, it's
much less clear-cut than that.
As I just mentioned, someone
who's quite marginal to the
story, like Albert, gets
to have the section.
So he obviously doesn't have the
centrality that Benjy or
Quentin or Jason --
that the three brothers do in
The Sound and the Fury.
Why does someone like Albert
get to tell the story?
Even though the two novels share
a common ground in terms
of multiple narrative voices,
the actual configuration of
those voices are two different
configurations in the two
novels.
And finally, something new is
also emerging in To Have and
Have Not that we haven't seen so
far or that hasn't been in
the foreground up
to this point.
And I'd like to call your
attention to it, which is
characters as generic types.
It has to do with
classification, with taxonomy
of social types.
We see it in the very
title of the novel.
It's divided into two, the
haves and the have-nots.
And obviously, two
social types.
It's very much an organizing
principle in this novel, but
it also looks forward to
Fitzgerald's stories that
we'll be reading next week.
A story like "The Rich Boy"
is very much about this
classifiable, generic type.
So I want to think about the
difference between the two
novels in terms of another novel
that Hemingway is famous
for, which is The Old
Man and the Sea.
And they're both set in Cuba.
They're both about Cuba to some
extent, but they're not
centrally about Cuba,
but set in Cuba.
But in many ways, they represent
two different sides
of the spectrum.
To Have and Have Not, as we can
see from the title, is a
divided canvas.
It's populated by two
taxonomic groups.
So it's very much about
classifiability.
Not only is it giving us two
taxonomic groups, but it's
also about the phenomenon
of classifiability.
Are human beings classified?
Can they be put under various
generic labels?
That is a big question
in this novel.
The Old Man and the Sea is in
many ways on the other side of
the spectrum.
As we can see and as you guys
know, the story, the novel, is
about a solitary Cuban
fisherman, Santiago, and his
decision to go out alone.
And he did get this
huge marlin--
once again, that fish--
and he's trying to save
that marlin from
being eaten up by sharks.
So the novel is really about
his struggle against the
sharks, and he loses out.
The marlin is completely cleaned
out by the sharks by
the end of the novel.
But in spite of that ending,
it is really about a heroic
struggle of a man against
elemental forces.
So most of us know Hemingway
actually as the Hemingway of
The Old Man and the Sea.
And it's helpful to
keep that in mind.
But Hemingway is also very
interested in the other side
of the equation, which is not
so much about individuals as
about individuals who can
be understood or can be
encompassed or accounted for
in terms of social types.
So we see it not only in the
main characters in the novel,
but also in very marginal
characters, people
who appear just once.
They're also presented to
us as social types.
So the very opening of the
novel, Harry Morgan is
approached by three young Cubans
who want to pay him a
lot of money to be taken
to the United States.
And this is how they
are described.
"They were good-looking young
fellows, wore good clothes.
None of them wore hats, and
they looked like they had
plenty of money.
They talked plenty of money,
anyway, and they spoke the
kind of English Cubans
with money speak."
So obviously classifiability
is front and
center in this passage.
The very syntax--
"they talked plenty of money"--
is an expression that
we use, and it certainly is the
kind of labeling that goes
on behind that kind of syntax.
So the outward appearance, the
clothes, the speech patterns
of these people easily
classify them.
We don't really need to know
much else about them, and
Hemingway is not interested
in telling us
much else about them.
They are just there as
representatives of Cubans with
money who need to get out
of Cuba at that moment.
But because classifiability
seems so central to the novel,
the question obviously arises
as to whether or not Harry
Morgan himself is
classifiable.
He is a hero, he's a
protagonist, who inhabits a
novel that is populated by
lots of social types.
Whether or not he belongs,
whether or not he fits
completely into that landscape
is the open question.
Is he able to break away
occasionally from that
landscape?
Does he manage to stand out and
be an individual that we
would recognize and that will
stick in our memories as one
individual rather than
as one social type?
That is the question that
we have to think about.
And I'd like to break that down
a little bit in terms of
four interconnected clusters
of issues.
One is to what extent is
Harry Morgan a racist?
Is he a racist, or is
he not a racist?
The other question--
and that's something that
we've already seen in
Faulkner, the play of pronouns,
and that is
highlighted, dramatized, by
Hemingway's choice of
narrative technique--
is whether he is an "I" or
whether he is a "he."
And the choice of those
pronouns obviously has
narrative implications.
If he is an "I," very likely
we're going to see
the inside of him.
It's going to be an interior
view of Harry.
If he's going to be a "he," very
likely, it's going to be
an external view of Harry.
Just as in Faulkner, there's an
external view and not very
pretty view of Dilsey in the
fourth section of The Sound
and the Fury.
And finally, going back to the
title of the novel, whether he
is a have or have-not.
Does he exit the novel
empty-handed?
Can you say that he has achieved
something, that
something is in his possession,
that he has
something, he owns something?
He owns a boat in
the beginning.
Whether he still owns anything
at all at the end of the
novel, that is an
open question.
I raised the question of racism,
because that is the
question raised by
Toni Morrison.
Toni Morrison, we know as
the author of novels.
We know her as a
novelist. She's
written novels like Beloved.
But she is also someone who
gives a lot of talks, and she
also turned some of those
talks into essays.
So Playing in the Dark is a
collection of essays published
by Toni Morrison.
And she devotes a long section
to Hemingway and To
Have and Have Not.
It's very interesting that this
is not the best-known
novel by Hemingway, but this
is the novel that Morrison
singles out, although she's
singling it out not to praise
it, but to point to some
troubling aspects of To Have
and Have Not.
And this is what
Morrison says.
"Harry includes a nigger in his
crew, a man who throughout
all of part one has no name.
His appearance is signaled by
the sentence, 'Just then, the
nigger we had getting bait comes
down to the dock.' The
black man is not only nameless
for five chapters, he's not
even hired.
Just someone we had getting
bait, a kind of trained
response, not an agent
possessing a job."
And then she goes on to say,
"The spatial and conceptual
difference is marked by the
shortcut that the term
'nigger' allows, with all
of its color and caste
implications.
The term occupies a territory
between man and animal."
Very, very strong objections
to the novel.
In response, I would like just
not to defend Hemingway
completely, but just to point
out that the word "nigger" is
used by Faulkner, as
we've just seen.
It is also used by Mark Twain,
because that's the word that
those characters would
have used.
Huck Finn would have used
the "nigger" in
the nineteenth century.
It would have been very odd for
Mark Twain not to use that
word in his novel.
Someone like Quentin, certainly
Jason, would have
used the word "nigger" if
they were living people.
So it would have been very odd
for Faulkner not to use that
word, because that's the basic
speech pattern of his
characters.
But Morrison actually concedes
that it's only in part one
that this black man doesn't
have a name.
He does have a name
in part two.
So we can look at that moment
of transition when the black
man acquires a name.
All of a sudden, we find
out what he's called.
But before we get to part two,
I just want to call attention
to a passage where the word
"nigger" is used, but not to
describe the black man that
Morrison has in mind.
This is an earlier appearance
of that word "nigger," and
this is actually coming right
after Harry's conversation
with those three rich Cubans.
All of a sudden, there's
this fighting
breaking out and shooting.
And it turns out that the key
player in that shooting is a
black character.
"The nigger with the Tommy gun
got his face almost into the
street and gave the back of
the wagon a burst from
underneath, and sure enough, one
came down, falling toward
the sidewalk with his
head above the curb.
At 10 feet, the nigger shot
him in the belly with the
Tommy gun, with what must have
been the last shot in it,
because I saw him
throw it down.
And old Pancho sat down hard
and went over forwards.
He was trying to come up, still
holding onto the Luger,
only he couldn't get his head
up when the nigger took the
shotgun that was lying against
the wheel of the car by the
chauffeur and blew the
side of his head off.
Some nigger."
So we might object to the
violence of the scene, but
what is clear in this passage
is the tremendous admiration
that Hemingway has for
this black character.
He's meant to kill.
His job is to kill the three
rich Cubans, and he
accomplishes that task
magnificently.
And Hemingway is just using
every bit of his writerly
skill to convey to us, even
those of us who really know
nothing about guns and nothing
about the art of shooting, to
highlight for us what an art
this is, to be able to get
your face almost down to the
street and to be able to get
someone, to get the shotgun when
there's nothing left in
your own Tommy gun and to be
able to finish off the last of
the three Cubans.
One against three.
It's just the performance
of it.
So there's nothing but
admiration in this description
of the black man.
And we can almost get a capsule
summary of the intense
admiration from the two-word
phrase that concludes the
passage, "some nigger."
Hemingway is still using the
word "nigger," but the
expression "some nigger"
almost completely undermines
that word.
Yes, he's a nigger.
He's a classifiable type.
But he's a magnificent
specimen.
He's an amazing specimen
of that type.
So much so that he's stretching
that type to its limit.
So much so that he's almost
making that type
non-functional.
He's such an amazing character
that it is almost--
you can call him a
nigger, but it
doesn't really mean anything.
He's "some nigger."
It turns out that that
construction, "some" followed
by what appears to be a
derogatory term, that is a
kind of a verbal tic
for Harry Morgan.
He uses that phrase over and
over again for other
characters as well.
So we can go and look at some
other instances when he uses
that construction.
And it turns out that he also
uses it for the man who owes
him $825, and he's
able to clear out
without paying a cent.
This is the very rich Mr.
Johnson who charters the boat
for fishing, manages to lose
all the works on the boat,
manages to do real damage to
Harry's boat because of his
ineptness as a fisherman.
And so he owes $825.
And this Mr. Johnson, even
though he is quite inept as a
fisherman, he nonetheless is
very skilled in one thing, and
this is what this passage
pays tribute to.
"'He went on the plane,"
Frankie said.
All right.
There it was.
The consulate was closed.
I had $0.40, and anyhow, the
plane was in Miami by now.
I couldn't even send a wire.
Some Mr. Johnson, all right.
It was my fault.
I should have known better.
Hell, I didn't even have enough
money to put in gas.
It was a hell of a
note, all right.
Some Mr. Johnson."
It is not the same kind of
performance as the shooting,
but it gets from Harry the same
involuntary admiration,
even though he's obviously the
victim of that magnificent
performance on the part
of Mr. Johnson.
It takes nerve.
It takes whatever,
ruthlessness.
We can attach any number of
adjectives to Mr. Johnson.
But Hemingway, in his much
more economic style of
writing, uses only one phrase,
and that is enough.
That is completely adequate
for Mr. Johnson.
There's no need for any string
of adjectives to be attached
to Mr. Johnson.
"Some Mr. Johnson,"
that does it all.
So we can see right away that
this is really Hemingway's way
of both paying tribute to
a generic type--in this
case, a rich man--
even his name is generic,
Mr. Johnson.
He's a generic type.
He's a generic rich man who
manages to get to be where he
is by what he does, by doing
certain numbers of things.
And he's very good at that.
So once again, this is a
specimen of a generic type
that is so good at what he's
doing that he stretches the
limit of that type.
One other example.
And this one is much more
analogous to the expression
"some nigger." We know that
actually even in Cuba, there's
a very significant--
even in Havana now, there's
a very important Chinese
population.
And it turns out that there is a
Chinese character in To Have
and Have Not.
He's a very smooth-talking,
smooth-looking Chinaman.
He wears a white suit and a silk
shirt with a black tie
and a $125 Panama hat.
So he also talks like this,
and Hemingway gives us a
specimen of the speech
pattern of this very
classifiable type.
He talks like an Englishman.
"'Quite so,' Mr. Sing said.
'How many of my unfortunate
compatriots could you both
accommodate?' 'You mean carry?'
He stood up, and I
watched him go out.
Frankie smiled at
him as he went.
Mr. Sing didn't look at him.
He was a smooth-looking
chink, all right.
Some chink."
So once again, this is a type
that outperforms the type by a
wide margin.
So this is about what kind of
performance can be expected
within a generic type and the
extent of that outperformance.
Even as a smooth talking
chink, Mr. Sing
is very, very memorable.
And we see it--
even when Mr. Sing is dead, he's
still memorable and still
more than just a specimen.
You guys probably know that Mr.
Sing is killed by Harry,
because he wants Harry basically
to kill off 12
Chinese passengers that he has
no intention of shipping to
where they thought
they were going.
So he wants Harry to kill those
12 Chinese passengers.
And instead of killing those 12
Chinese passengers, Harry
kills Mr. Sing, but not without
a lot of resistance,
very heroic resistance,
magnificent
resistance, from Mr. Sing.
And this is the outcome.
He's dead, he's killed
by Harry, but he's
left a mark on Harry.
And this is actually the
beginning of the bodily
injuries sustained by Harry.
This is actually one of the
structural principles in the
novel is the things that
eat into Harry's body.
And that is part of the catalog
of things that we can
put on the have-not column.
Harry starts with--
he's an able-bodied person.
He's complete.
He has all his body parts, and
he gradually loses some parts
of his body, or parts of his
body will get damaged.
So this is the first instance
of something that happens to
his body, and it's coming to
him because of Mr. Sing.
"I held the wheel with my knee
and opened up my shirt and saw
where Mr. Sing bit me.
It was quite a bite, and
I put iodine on it.
And then I sat there steering
and wondering whether a bite
from a Chinaman was poisonous.
Hell, no, that bite
wasn't poisonous.
A man like that Mr. Sing
probably scrubbed his teeth
two or three times a day.
Some Mr. Sing."
This is Hemingway writing and
not Faulkner, but we see the
same mixture of tragedy
and comedy right
here in full display.
So it is not a great experience
to be bitten by
anyone, and this seems to
be a very bad bite.
But the bite is also an occasion
on what a generic,
smooth-looking chink would do.
He's going to be brushing his
teeth three or four times a
day, and you can count on his
hygiene to save you from
getting any infection
from his bite.
So this one consoling fact--
that if you have to be bitten,
it's better to be bitten by
the likes of Mr. Sing than
to be by someone else--
that is the dark comedy
that is emerging in To
Have and Have Not.
But it also is a meditation
really on all
those derogatory labels.
And the question to us as to
whether or not we should
consider them allowable, whether
or not we should say,
this is an instance where it
is completely legitimate to
use those words, or whether we
still think that some other
word would have been
preferred.
So I encourage you to talk about
this issue in section.
But now I'd like to switch to
part two of To Have and Have
Not and to the possibility
that Harry Morgan himself
might actually be portrayed as
a type, as dramatized and
reinforced by Hemingway's
narrative technique.
So we're switching to the
third-person narration and a
very jolting outside view
of Harry Morgan.
And this is also the moment
when the black character
actually acquires a name.
"'I'm sorry, Wesley,' the man
said, 'but I got to steer.'
'You treat a man no better than
a dog,' the nigger said.
He was getting ugly now,
But the man was
still sorry for him.
'I'm going to make you
comfortable, Wesley,' he said.
'You just lay quiet.' 'You ain't
going to fix me up,' the
nigger said.
The man, whose name was Harry
Morgan, said nothing then,
because he liked the nigger,
and there was nothing to do
now but hit him, but he
couldn't hit him."
It almost seems an act of
deliberate hostility against
his own character, after so many
pages when we're inside
the head and inside the skin of
Harry Morgan, to encounter
that phrase, "the man, whose
name was Harry Morgan." It
can't be more externalizing
than that.
It can't be more objectifying
What is interesting is that that
objectifying description
is actually used for a white
protagonist in the same moment
when the black character
is acquiring a name.
So this double dynamics suggests
that this is a very,
very important moment.
The black character acquires a
name, and the white character
also acquires a name,
but in a bad way.
When he had been telling the
story, he doesn't refer to
himself as Harry Morgan.
For the white character to
acquire a name and to be
referred to as "the man, whose
name was Harry Morgan" puts
him in almost exactly the same
structural position as the
black man, Wesley.
Each of them acquires a name,
except that for the black
character to acquire a name is
a good thing, whereas for the
white character, acquiring a
name is about the worst thing
that can happen to him
at that moment.
Why is it that Hemingway would
suddenly switch to this
third-person narration and this
very alienating mechanism
that has been visited
upon Harry Morgan?
We can think of a number
of issues.
In part one, we sort of know
what Harry does for a living.
Why does this man have a boat?
We have our conjectures.
But in part two, all of that
is being clarified for us.
We know that the black
man is shot.
And there's the smell of liquor
all over the boat.
The boat itself is referred
to as the booze boat.
So we know that's what Harry
does is that he smuggles
liquor into the United States.
He becomes just that.
That's his profession, and
that's what we know him by.
That takes over the intimate,
internal view that we had of
him in part one.
And because that is the
occupation that lands him in
this very tight spot with his
companion, the black man,
Wesley, being shot.
And we also know that something
else as well, that
Wesley is not the only one to
be shot on that occasion, as
we find out in this
next description.
"'Who the hell's shot worse?'
He asked him.
'You or me?' 'You're shot
worse,' the nigger said.
'But I ain't never been shot.
I didn't figure to get shot.
I ain't paid to get shot.
I don't want to be shot.' 'Take
it easy, Wesley,' the
man told him.
'It don't do you any good
to talk like that.'"
Just this one little detail
that in fact both
of them were shot--
because they obviously
had a run-in.
The booze boat was discovered.
And so it was a major event with
casualties in both Harry
and Wesley.
So far, what is in the
foreground in part two is the
casualties that were sustained
by Wesley, and that's what
he's complaining about.
He's making everyone aware
that he's been shot.
The extent of Harry's wound is
revealed to us in this very
oblique, very marginal
mention--
"'Who the hell's shot worse?' he
asked. 'You or me?' 'You're
shot worse.'" So Wesley
acknowledges that actually the
more serious wound
is on Harry.
But we don't actually
know what the
consequences might be.
Because right now, the limelight
is really on Wesley
and the fact that he's furious
for having gotten shot, for
going on this trip with Harry,
and Harry trying his best to
appease Wesley.
And then in the rest of part
two, we also have this outside
character, Frederick Harrison,
who takes up a lot of the
space in part two, wanting
to report Harry to the
authorities.
So part two is in many ways a
part of the story in which we
see Harry as someone who should
be reported to the
authorities, someone who is the
recipient of complaint, of
ill will, of anger, of a grudge,
at the very least,
from Wesley, and who's also
someone that an outsider would
want to report to
the authorities.
He's someone who's doing
something illegal, and he's
outside the law in many ways.
So all of that suggests that
it is fitting that in part
two, the story should be told
from outside of his point of
view, that we're no longer
inside his skin.
We're just seeing him as he is
seen by other people, as he's
seen by Wesley, as he's seen by
Captain Willie, who tries
to protect him, as he is seen
through the binoculars by
Frederick Harrison, who
wants to report him.
So he really is an object, he's
a seen object, and it is
fitting that a seen object
should be conveyed to us
through the third-person
narration.
But I think that there's also
another reason why Hemingway
would want to switch from
first-person narration to
third-person narration.
It's that already in part two,
we're beginning to see a
symmetry between Harry and
the black man, Wesley.
We just saw that both of them
acquire a name in part two.
We now see in this moment that
they are also linked.
They are kindred in one sense.
They are kindred in a narrative
sense, in the same
way that Benjy, Quentin, and
Jason are kindred in a
narrative sense in
Faulkner's novel.
These two are kindred in a
narrative sense, because the
same thing happens to
them, being shot.
That is the tie between
this black character
and this white character.
And the only difference between
them, actually, is the
degree of severity
of that shot.
And here, actually, we know that
it is the black man who
actually has the lighter wound,
that it's the white
protagonist who's
suffering more,
actually, on this occasion.
So both the commonality between
the white character
and the black character, but
also a potential line of
differentiation, in the sense
that it's the person who has
the lighter wound who's being
taken care of by Harry.
Let's then go to Chapter 9,
which is in part three.
And here, this is a chapter that
is told by Albert, the
very marginal character.
So it is told from Albert's
point of view, but Harry is
once again seen from
the outside.
He is a "he" in part
three, Chapter 9.
But what is also interesting
about part three, Chapter 9,
is that it basically is a
revisiting of an earlier
moment between Harry
and Wesley.
And now we know the consequences
of that gunshot
wound earlier.
"'What happened to your arm?'
the lawyer asked Harry.
Harry has the sleeve pinned
up to the shoulder.
'I didn't like the look
of it, so I cut it
off,' Harry told him.
'You and who else cut it off?'
'Me and a doctor cut it off,'
Harry said."
I think that Hemingway really
wants that shock that comes
from that lack of knowledge
in part two.
Part two goes on for quite a
while, and all the time when
we're reading about Frederick
Harrison, we have no idea that
the wound is serious
enough that the arm
would have to be amputated.
And it's the withholding of that
information in part two
that maximizes it
in part three.
It is a shock to us that
that is what will have
to happen to Harry.
And none of that would have been
conveyed to us if Harry
had been telling the story.
It is impossible to talk about
the amputation of the arm with
this kind of dramatic
impersonality that Hemingway
is aiming for.
If it had been told from Harry's
point of view, it
would have been about his pain,
but Hemingway is not
into conveying the inside
view of pain.
That is not the phenomenal
field that
he chooses to enter.
Some other novelists do a
great job within that
phenomenal field.
That is not Hemingway's
chosen subject.
What he wants is to give us
that complete impersonal,
neutral, almost joking
kind of look at
someone losing his arm.
And that can only be achieved
by looking at
Harry from the outside.
So the combination of the
straightforward, third-person
narration in part two and then
Albert telling the story in
part three, Chapter 9, the
combination of those maximizes
the shock of realizing that,
really, Harry is starting to
lose something.
He's well on his way in his
trajectory towards the
have-not category.
He's well on his way.
Losing one's arm is quite
different from losing lots of
other things, to
say the least.
So we've just seen that Harry
has something in common with
Wesley, but we also see that
he has something else in
common with someone
else as well.
Because of course someone else
prior to this had also lost
his arm, Mr. Sing.
In the fight between Harry and
Mr. Sing, Harry tries to bend
Mr. Sing's arm behind him, and
at one point, he just hears
this funny little noise that is
made when an arm is broken.
And then he lets go of the arm,
because the arm isn't
good to Mr. Sing anymore.
So we've seen that dramatized
rendition of someone losing
his arm and this deliberately
undramatized rendition of
someone losing his arm and only
appearing as a man without--
for Harry to appear as a man
without an arm, as seen by the
doctor by a lawyer.
So once again, it's Harry as a
seen object, but still the
common ground is there.
He and Mr. Sing actually do
have something in common.
Mr. Sing loses his arm.
He loses his life.
Harry loses his arm.
Whether or not he's going to
lose his life like Mr. Sing is
the open question in To
Have and Have Not.
So this is a novel that actually
it is very hard to
predict the ending of this
novel, so I'm very happy not
to tell you the ending
and just leave
it as an open question.
To what extent is the symmetry
between Harry and Mr. Sing
going to extend?
How far does that extend?
But just one more meditation on
the question of having and
not having.
It seems that Harry actually
is quite aware that he's on
his way to becoming
a have-not.
But he has his own way of
classifying himself.
So this is one character's
attempt to classify himself in
his own fashion.
And what is going to be used
as the criteria for
classifying the haves
and the have-not?
You can classify people by the
amount of money they have, or
you can classify them by whether
or not they have arms,
or you can classify them
by something else.
So here is Harry proposing
to classify
himself in his own fashion.
"'The hell with my arm.
You lose an arm, you
lose an arm.
There's worse things
than lose an arm.
You've got two arms,
and you've got two
of something else.
And a man's still a man with one
arm or with one of those.
The hell with it,' he says.
'I don't want to talk about it.'
Then after a minute, he
says, 'I got those other
two still.'"
So this is the celebrated
concept of the cojones that
Harry still has, a word that
Hemingway is very fond of.
And that's how he would like
to classify himself.
Maybe the arm is the most
obvious thing that people see,
but the most obvious thing is
not actually the thing that
best classifies someone.
Something that is invisible
could be a better classifier.
So I think that the novel
entertains that question is,
how much can you lose?
Harry is going to lose a lot
of things in the course of
this novel.
You can keep on losing
a lot of things and
still remain yourself.
At least, that's the hope, or
maybe that's a fantasy.
We have to decide whether it is
a legitimate hope, a real
hope, a hope that actually has
some grounding in reality, or
whether it is just a fantasy,
whether at a certain point
when you've lost so much, that
you really have stopped being
yourself, you're no longer what
you used to be, whether
that is indeed the case.
So we'll come back and wrap up
the novel, but think more
about where we should
put Harry.